осінь довгі
дощі
тумани на
асфальті вода і
бруд одинокі стоять
екрани не цікавлять промоклий Люд тільки
Джаз в ресторані
Рин
[музика]
[оплески]
танцтеатр життя наш легендарний
танцтеатр життя Сьогодні в нас немає
дощу хоча у Львові я впевнена навіть у
дощ Прекрасна ми запросили вас на вечір
джазу тож зобов'язані розпочати з
Богдана веселовського без нього ніяк а
ти знаєш що веселовський коли написав
своє танго не мав навіть 22 років і він
добистями добистями кохав ірену яросевич
яку потім знав весь світ як ірену Андерс
ренату
богданську це було прекрасне Юне щире
кохання і я думаю що у кожній Львівській
кнайпі прекрасного осіннього вечора
лунало тоді прийде Ще час коли затужиш
ти за мною тож прийде Ще час для вас
прекрасне товариство співає Павло
[музика]
Ільницький
ще раз поглянути на тебе з тобою
стрінути ще раз увечер як зірки засяд в
небі Осінній вечір Як тільки день погас
ще раз підти двох з тобою за руки
взявшись я колись в гаях спшках ми
осінню сумною де перший раз Ми давно
зійшлись прийде Ще час Скали закружети
за
мноювай прийде Ще час коли згадаєш наші
[музика]
ді Може тоді любов ти зрозумієш
мою І може за ту любов вдячно буде
мені
поглянути твої очі і слухати слова твої
усейдиві місяця літньої ночі послухать
ще як співаю сонуіже
лише це мрі Невже лише це ті пісни Чому
Чому пропалася Надія івяла тако Квіт на
весні прийде Ще
часли за ти за
мною вийде ще жас коли задаєш наші
ді Може
тоді любов ти зрозумієш
мою І може за ту любов вдячна буде з
[музика]
мені
пуска прийде Ще час коли затужеш ти за
мной прийде Ще час коли задаєш наші
дні А я ще маю па Може тоді любов ти
зрозумієш
мою І може за ту любов вдячна будеш
[музика]
не
коли затужеш ти за
МНО
прийдешся час коли задає наші
дні може тобі любов ти зрозумієш
мою І може за ту любов вдячна будеш
[музика]
[сміх]
бездоганна
[музика]
родина
я на
зараз с
[музика]
and
Little
[музика]
ві
there's
[музика]
Nothing When mommy and
D
[музика]
уї
дайте
[музика]
дяку
кільки
можнавіть Павло ільницьки прекрасні
музиканти яких ми представимо трошки
пізніше
дяку шановні пані та панове якщо хтось
чекає офіційної частини вона обов'язково
буде але не сьогодні Сьогодні у нас
прекрасний святковий осінній теплий вечр
сьогодні тільки джаз
львіввати зрештою Львів бачився Львів
знаєся великий
даже
львовавів залишає тільки льво його
толерантність закінчується рівно У той
момент коли починає звучати мова окупан
освободи Львів місто вибагливе Воно
приймає не кожного його можна любити Та
щоб сподіватися на взаємність треба
пройти серйозний культурний патріотичний
та інтелектуальний фільтр але зрештою
Львів завжди мислив глобально І
стратегічно правильно ще з перших
президентських коли у Львові переміг
Чорновіл так і тепер Львів зробив свій
правильний вибір тому що Львів не купиш
Ні за гречку ні за якісь ще обіцянки
Львів ніколи не помиляється Я дуже на це
сподіваюся що так і буде далі найкращі
пісні мабуть написані під львівськими
осінніми дощами Франко і кос
анатольський Тільки у Львові міг
народитися такий Тандем хоч і розділений
в часі і я з великою
приємністю хочу представити у виконанні
соліста Львівської національної опери
мого партнера по сцені улюбленця
Львівської публіки Петра радейка І він
для вас виконає улюблений український
Роман родини порошенків Ой ти дівчино з
горіха зерня Дякую Ірино Петро
Радейко
[музика]
ойти
дівчино з
горіхазерня Чом твоє
серденько
полю
щом твої
устонька
Тиха
Молитва А твоє
слово
остре як бритва
щом твої
очі
сяють тим
ча щото
запалює серце
[музика]
пожаро Ох Ті
очі
темніші
ночі хто в них
задивиться і сонця не
схоче і чові
усміх для мене
скрута серце
бетежить як Буря
Люта Ой ти
дівчино
ясна я
зоре ти мої
радощі ти
моєго
[музика]
Ой ти
дівчино з горіхазерня
Чом твоє
серденько
[музика]
колючетерня тебе
видаю люби ти
мушу
тебе
кохаючи загублю
душу Ти моя
радість Ти мо
єго Ой ти
дівчино
[музика]
яснаяре
Браво Петро Радейко і неймовірний романс
до речі він був написаний ще у
1956 а дотепер дотепер ми його слухаємо
з таким задоволення з такою
насолодою Ти знаєш я думаю що стати на
площі Ринок це ще не означає відчути
Львів а сидіти у ратуші не означає
розуміти його тому що щоб Підкорити
Львів треба
підкоритисяі і ти знаєш я думаю що треба
підкоритися львовум підкоритися його
історії підкоритися оцьому духу Франка
Родини
Крушельницьких родини дедисидентів
калинців Я знаю що сьогодні пані дзвінка
халинець присутня
тут можеш взяти якщо можна пані дзвінко
дайте ось бачу іде до нас пані дзвінка
Калинець діть до нас будь ласка я я ось
тут діть до мене сюди пані дзвінко Та ми
вас закличимо буквально на кілька слів
Доброго дня Доброго вечора скажіть будь
ласка в нас сьогодні тема Львова
осіннього європейського Львова чи саме
про такий Львів Який зараз є мріяли ваші
батьки я тішуся що мій тато ще є і може
сам прекрасно татой вповіть про яки він
Львів мріяв я можу сказати про маму тому
що мене
виховували в таких певних почуттях
любові і до України і безперечно до
рідного Львова а взагалі львівні
асоціюється з поезією Ростислава братиня
пісня львів'янки
з тих чаів про Львів написано багато
гарних пісень але це якась
особливо Львів місто
європейське Львів
місто безперечно прекрасною архітектури
Але найголовніше в моєму житті що Львів
- це патріотичне місто Львів національно
свідоме місто і саме Львів завжди задає
тон цілій Україні і це мабуть є
найважливіше для нас для наших дітей для
всіх хтото сьогодні зібрався європейська
осінь у національному і
патріотичному дякую дякую вам власне
пані двінка згадала за пісню львів'янки
Ростислава раня А я хочу згадати ще одну
пісню Прекрасну на слова Ростислава
братання музика Володимира Сьогодні в
нас
получились звучить прекрасне річ так
дякує цікаві розмови у Львові завжди
відбуваються при каві або за келихом
доброго вина сьогодні є кава вино і є
непересічні
співрозмовни Де наш найголовніший батя
де найголовніший батя де є Юрко виничук
пане Юрій пане Юрій покажіться нам будь
ласка щоб ми з вами могли
поспілкуватися пря пря куди ось туди ось
туди пане
Юрі головний Львівський батяр сучасності
пане Юрію Доброго вечора вам ви як
львів'янин з великої літери Скажіть будь
ласка чи справжні Батяри пишаються
сучасним Львовом е ну намагаюся пишатися
оскільки відроджено батяра і нарешті є
свято сучасний Львівський патяр Ось які
він
має я мав вам зараз поділитися спогадами
своєю бурхливою но це буде нажа довго
іцікаво але ви можете прочитати мої
книжки такі як до кісті або вік вестяні
ігри в осних садах і там описано всі мої
походеньки і моїх
друзів чисто батярські такі що є щого
пос яке місце саме у Львові для вас ось
таке
найвизначніш Ну знаєте я зараз патріотом
Винників бо я живу в Винниках то для
мене зараз Винники це
моя велика батьківщина Дякую вам за
хорошу розмову Ну а справжній Бат завжди
вміє
танцювати будь ласка
чудес запрош крас зреш тепер
чоловікі співає Ірина доля та
Павло
падає
[музика]
добре
в
[музика]
вибачте
забояли по заразкину
тижераз
жде дівчина
[музика]
жде
ку
[музика]
велид на
свя
і зараз Софією синюткою
[музика]
ісь
сгодні
[музика]
ось і вечір вівці біля броду
черемоша п'ють холодну
воду у садочку вівчера
стрічає дівчинонька
що його
кохає
всюди
бу